hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sail israels
heute hab ich ein rezept für das tram
adam special und zwar gibt es heute eine
tomatensuppe
das ist eher so eine türkische
tomatensuppe mit etwas reis noch mit
drin und die essen wir wirklich sehr
gerne vor allem samira ist sie gerne
weil im prinzip ist sowieso eine
tomatensoße mit bisher reis drin und es
ist vor allem im sommer finde ich sehr
erfrischend ich brauche dafür einen
esslöffel olivenöl einen esslöffel
butter einen esslöffel mehl und einen
esslöffel tomatenmark eine kleine
zwiebel oder eine halbe große zwiebel
eine dose tomaten sind 400 gramm
ich habe ich noch gewürze unseren halben
teelöffel salz und viertel teelöffel
chili und jeweils einen teelöffel
oregano rosmarin und minze etwas pfeffer
und 50 gramm langkornreis ich nehme
jetzt zuerst einmal die zwiebel und die
schneide ich jetzt in feine würfel
heimlich bereits einen topf erhitzt und
kann da einen esslöffel olivenöl
gemeinsam mit abrutscher rhein geben
wobei die butter geschmolzen ist
kompatibel mit rein
und durch die zwiebeln bekommen ist
natürlich den richtig tollen würzigen
geschmack gehen
sie werden jetzt etwas 23 minuten
gebraten und da können wir jetzt auch
ein bisschen runter stellen damit bibel
noch keinen fall verbrennen
als nächstes gebe ich jetzt tomatenmark
und mädel dazu das wird es auch nur eine
minute mit gebraten und ich finde gerade
diese kombination wirklich sehr lecker
so dieser duft mit butter und dem mehl
und empfehlen und den angebratenen
tomatenmark richtig genial
jetzt möchte ich das ganze mit den
tomaten dann nehme ich jetzt auch
tomaten aus der dose weil sie sehr
aromatisch sind jetzt völlig diese dose
zweimal mit wasser wenn jetzt lasse ich
die suppe auf höchster stufe aufkochen
unser etwa 10 bis 15 minuten köcheln
aber auf jeden fall kann man jetzt schon
mal auch die gewürze dazugeben und dann
auch pfeffer und dann gebe ich dann
gleich den deckel drauf nach dem
aufkochen wird die suppe bei leicht
geöffnetem deckel und mittlerer hitze
für zehn minuten weiter gekocht
die suppe dürfte jetzt kochen
jetzt könnt ihr sie entweder so lassen
dann habt ihr so eine etwas stöckige
suppe so wie jetzt hier
oder ihr könnt sie zum beispiel mit
einem pürierstab pürieren oder er macht
so wie ich streiche nämlich durch und
zieht damit ich dir ganz feine suppe
bekommen wahrscheinlich kurz den herd
aus und streicht sie hier durch den sieg
durch
jetzt kommt die super wieder zurück in
den topf und dabei ist jetzt noch einmal
aufkochen natürlich auch salz und
pfeffer nochmals abschmecken und sobald
sie kocht kommt der reise noch mehr so
die suche muss jetzt so lange kochen bis
der reis da ist und die zwischenzeit
nutze ich um ein paar kartons
herzustellen
ich brauche einen esslöffel butter vier
esslöffel olivenöl eine bio zitrone eine
knoblauchzehe und zwei scheiben brot
ich nehme es direkt das brot und
schneidet in kleine würfel
da kann man zum beispiel auch mal altes
brot nehmen viele schneiden die rinde
immer weg ich das einfach immer gerne
dran mal was will man sonst mit der
rinde machen wegschmeißt findet ihr
zuschaute wie etwa 1 cm große würfel
jetzt kann ich die knoblauchzehen fein
hacken und ich nehme auch zwei chilis
habe ich eben vergessen aber die kommen
auch nur mit rein wenn ihr möchtet wenig
cluster einfach weg bietet beides fein
gewürfelt
jetzt gebe ich butter und öl in einer
pfanne und zwar sorgt es dafür dass die
bürger nicht verbrennt und die butter
gibt eben einen tollen geschmack des
engels jetzt griff jetzt ständig die
hitze aber ein bisschen runter so auf
stufe 3 von 9 also ins untere drittel
und jetzt kommen die chilis und die
knoblauchzehen mit dazu sie geben dann
nämlich den geschmack an das öl ab und
da kommt noch die zitronenschale mit
rein
jetzt stelle ich die hitze wieder ein
bisschen hoch so auf stufe fünf etwa
jetzt kommen die brotwürfel mit rein und
wenn dann so lange gerüstet bis der
knusprig sind
die quoten sind jetzt knusprig die werde
ich jetzt noch mit salz und pfeffer
würzen
und in die suppe kommt noch einen
spritzer zitronensaft der ohne den
geschmack auch wirklich sehr gut ab und
dann kann ich die suppe auch schon
servieren
als vorspeise reicht die suppe übrigens
für etwa vier personen und als
hauptspeise so für etwa zwei personen
ich reiche es noch einen naturjoghurt
mit dazu der hat 35 teil man kann
natürlich auch in höheren fettanteil
nehmen das bringt geschmacklich und
farblich noch mal so ein bisschen
kontrast mit rein und dann auf die cote
times
falls beide suppe und bei den gut horst
kinder mit essen würde ich auf jeden
fall die schärfe ein bisschen weglassen
und vielleicht im nachhinein dann dazu
geben dann kann jeder selber selber die
schärfe regulieren und nach eigenem
belieben mit dazu geben
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall ganz
viel spaß beim nachmachen und nachkochen
und wir sehen uns das nächste mal wieder
bis bald
ich stehe gerade mit der lieben tiere in
meiner küche wir haben den ganzen tag
diese tolle torte gebacken und wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie wir die torte gebacken
haben und warum dann schaut einfach um
16 15 beim kika bei der sendung schon
meine welt bis später wir freuen uns